hey everyone I'm agent Bibbs if you
really have a hard-on for being formal
call me mr. Beebe's I don't so if you
call me mr. Beebe's I'll throw a pen cap
at you now I've got a few guesses as to
why the higher-ups wanted me to run this
class but I'll deal with that later for
right now you get the oh so wonderful
privilege of hearing me talk about being
an intelligence agent for the foundation
you know I think I'm going to like this
group
this isn't me slobbing your knobs or
anything I'm serious
see most of you screw heads then pick up
any of the food or drinks it means you
don't trust free food given that by
someone you don't know that's a good
thing because in about three seconds
okay so I'm off by two seconds plus or
minus Hey using knockout drops it's an
inexact science which is good because
I'm not all that good on the whole
science thing I only gave me the
researcher role because I kept figuring
out what the eggheads we're going to do
before they did Christ's sake
while the DS get the idiots out of here
let's get down to business
by the way D four four six three two
take Fred there to a sell his church now
how did I know all this you lunkheads am
i genius well got it
but that's not the point the point is
before you guys came in and sat down I
went over each and every one of your
dossiers the ones you gave us and the
ones my fellow is compiled on each and
every bunny its how I realized the
majority of this group wouldn't take
food from a stranger and how Fred was a
jerk plant I don't do all this
background looking in the ship because
it's impressive to the newbies well
partially I do mostly no it's because
it's my job to know [ __ ] it's my job
because the foundation needs to know
[ __ ] [ __ ] we don't know about we can
keep people safe from yes James who wet
the bed till he was six I said people
let the eggheads frame things in a way
that lets them avoid thinking about 7
billion people your agents you're
dealing with people good people bad
people good bad people bad good people
and cliff I guess he's not really people
though I think no Alexander put your
hand down I'm not going to talk to you
about cliff he's one of your bosses and
he's smarter than you seeking out more
than that'll give you a headache but no
you're gonna think you're smart enough
to find out the truth about if you're
lucky you'll warn you off if you're not
he'll tell you everything don't pout
Alex
prove me wrong it happened so rarely I'm
gonna sit down and put my feet up on the
table to complete the whole arrogant
prick look yeah these are gym shoes
running a dress shoes is a [ __ ] and a
half 40 percent of a nice job is based
on rug right anyways being an ia you'll
get up and you'll find a folder on your
table or in my case stuck to the wall of
the containment cell I took over when
they decided to recruit my surprisingly
firm ass it'll be all professional like
brief as hell we're talking location
rough approximation of what the
higher-ups expect how you'll be getting
there maybe a few suggestions on the
tire and the like I tell you to ignore
the last one but if I do that you'll
wear a clown suit to the GOC facility
that only works once
or twice a week out that Pam in March on
the way to wherever you're going you'll
be studying the location not the
quote-unquote specific foundation stuff
no I'm talking about cultural [ __ ] you
know do the people where you're going
have a strong oral tradition are the men
or women more open to talking to people
do they respond well to Authority or is
it better to be one of the guys you're
here because you either know that kind
of [ __ ] already or you know people who
know people who know that [ __ ] as long
as you don't tell your buddies you're
with the foundation nobody here really
gives a rat's ass who you talk to
yeah the higher-ups talk about super
obnoxious secrecy and all things but as
because most of them were never agents
in the first place you'll get the
wherever you need to go and then the fun
starts if there's places the foundation
wants you to examine you do it otherwise
do whatever you need to do go into a bar
drink a bit talk with the locals ask if
there's been any crazy stories floating
about most are relevant to what you're
doing but learn them anyway you'll build
trust and you'll have do cover stories
for your next few missions take notes
follow up on these notes make sure
they're legit in short learn [ __ ] that's
why the foundation pays you a lot of
goddamn money and that's why you're here
and still where you were no man don't
raise your hand and nobody cares you
used to work for the CIA
I ran loops around your former bosses
had a few months ago after I started
here I think I got fired for not
thinking about it long story
his fault yeah I'm aware he's your
father I'm talking you're not I speak
you learn [ __ ] for my massive brain -
you're probably larger but empty brain
seriously I don't know if anyone's told
you but your head is huge
as I was saying you've done your
canvassing and your network you found
out what the higher-ups are looking for
and you've got as much info as you can
get on the thing where exactly it is
best way and time to get at it things to
know to ensure a clean retreat you have
to ask yourself if you learn enough [ __ ]
you ain't learned enough [ __ ] you want
your fellow foundation ayats that get
your anal-retentive actually scratch
that be anal retentive if you don't put
down that the skip turns blue at 11:34
p.m. on Fridays someone is going to
[ __ ] die this is when you expect me
to chuckle and point out how pointless
that sort of detail is newsflash you're
in the foundation now stuff turning blue
can and will cause someone to die I've
seen it happen this is our three of you
guys flagged for wanting to play hero
I'm going to make this very clear to
everyone don't beachings
god damn bond your intelligence dammit
and running into capture a skip on your
own is going to get your ass killed
leave it to the retrieval and
containment agents let them get their
asses killed no if the RNC teams get
killed you didn't give them enough [ __ ]
to go see these names of my arm three
men died because I failed to give them
enough information for a clean retreat I
don't plan on adding any more I'm not
sure if you guys know this but tattoos
they hurt actually here's a teaching
don't get tattoos ink identifies you and
your job as an intelligence agent is not
to be [ __ ] identified I know what
you're thinking my badge allowed to get
what and I'm not well first off I'm
better at being an I even you
secondly I've been here longer than you
I'm granted a wider latitude thirdly I
was the one who discovered an anomalous
brand of ink that vanishes when you
mentally will it - okay it's mostly a
third one but the first two still apply
I know you know get the SPECIAL ink I
found it and it was the one anomalous
item I got to take possession of this
year
[ __ ] I'm digressing again anyway back to
being an ia when you're done getting all
your [ __ ] together get out of there
without making a fuss on your way home
right up your reports when you reach
your home site you'll be formally
debriefed the [ __ ] you provide will be
filed and processed into a form that the
RNC's won't even bother reading because
it's about how to get to their goal
without shooting everything inside I'm
kidding sort of oh and one last thing
before I dismiss you guys being an
intelligence agent isn't just about
getting into places it's also about
getting out of places while we've been
talking this entire room has been moved
and deposited into one of our larger
containment cells quite a few exits head
back to the facility and each one seals
off after a person uses it you're being
time okay this is [ __ ] I pulled the
text on one of the lights to go off when
I said you're being timed I thought it
would look badass new lesson never trust
bill that [ __ ] always thinks
it's funny to ruin the one moment when I
get to look badass at the newbies you
know what you guys are dismissed I'm
going oh there they go Christ
forgot our darker Goods up so yeah
forget that stuff about Bill find your
way out and have fun with it I'll be
here taking a nap
you
you